you may qualify to get Eargo at
no cost to you.
BRIAN:  ALL RIGHT, DR. ANTHONY
FAUCI WHOSES LATEST FLOP IS
COLLEGE FOOTBALL PREDICTION,
REMEMBER?
RIGHT NOW IS WHERE WE NORMALLY
ROLL IN THE CLIP BUT HE SAID
OVER AND OVER AGAIN, HE LOOKED
AT THOSE BIG CROWDS AND HE SAYS
ESSENTIALLY, IN HIS FULL
DELIVERY, WELL LET’S LISTEN.
>> WHAT WAS YOUR SORT OF
IMMEDIATE THOUGHT WHEN YOU SAW
ALL OF THOSE FANS PACKED INTO
STADIUMS IN TEXAS, WISCONSIN,
AND ELSEWHERE, AS SOON AS I SAW
IT, I THOUGHT COVID IS ABOUT TO
HAVE A FEAST.
WHAT DID YOU THINK?
>> I THOUGHT THE SAME THING.
I THINK IT’S REALLY UNFORTUNATE.
I WOULD HOPE THAT MOST OF THE
PEOPLE IN THAT STADIUM WERE
VACCINATED AND EVEN IF THEY WERE
, THE CLOSE KONG REGATHERING
SETTING SHOULD HAVE BEEN WEARING
MASKS.
BRIAN:  OUTDOORS, TWO WEEKS
LATER, COVID-19 DATA IS IN.
SOME OF THE BIGGEST GAMES WERE
HELD, AND GUESS WHAT HAPPENED?
NOTHING.
THE STANDS WERE PACKED, THERE
WEREN’T SUPER SPREADERS IN FACT
THE RATES WENT DOWN IN THOSE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES,
LIKE IN TEXAS, DESPITE THE
UNIVERSITY OF TEXAS AND
TEXAS A &M BOTH HOSTING GAMES
SEPTEMBER 4, THAT DREW NEARLY
190,000 FANS BETWEEN THEM THE
STATEWIDE SEVEN DAY AVERAGE,
CURRENTLY IS LOWER THAN IT WAS
ON GAME DAY.
HERE TO REACT OUTKICK FOUNDER
CLAY TRAVIS.
CLAY?
YOUR REACTION TO WHAT THE
PREDICTION WAS FOR DR. FAUCI
AS OPPOSED TO THE REALITY WE’RE
LIVING IN.
>> LOOK, ALL OVER THE SOUTH,
FIRST OF ALL THANKS FOR HAVING
ME, BRIAN, MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
HAVE GONE TO COLLEGE FOOTBALL
GAMES AND THE NUMBER OF COVID
INFECTIONS HAS BEEN PLUMMETING.
YOU JUST REFERENCED TEXAS, SAME
THING HAS HAPPENED IN FLORIDA,
IN GEORGIA, IN ALABAMA, IN
MISSISSIPPI, ALL OF THESE STATES
THAT HAVE HAD MASSIVE CROWDS FOR
THEIR COLLEGE FOOTBALL GAMES
, ALL OVER THE SOUTH, WE
ARE SEEING CASES COME DOWN,
MEANING, WHEN DR. FAUCI SAID HE
WAS WORRIED ABOUT SUPER SPREADER
EVENTS OVER THESE MAJOR COLLEGE
FOOTBALL CROWDS, JUST FLAT OUT
HASN’T MATERIALIZED.
IN FACT, BRIAN, THE OPPOSITE HAS
HAPPENED.
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT ARE
TESTING POSITIVE FOR COVID, ALL
OVER THE SOUTH, IS PLUMMETING TO
A MASSIVE DEGREE.
BRIAN:  CLAY, THINK ABOUT THIS.
YOU NOW HAVE A SITUATION WHERE
CHINA OPPRESSES, THEY WILL EVEN
LET YOU DIE AND WHITHER AWAY IN
AN APARTMENT IF YOU’RE POSITIVE
AND IT STILL CAME BACK.
THEN YOU HAVE PERMISSIVE AREAS
AND IT STILL COMES BACK AND IT
GOES AWAY.
MIGHT THE VIRUS HAVE A SAY IN
HOW IT SPREADS?
>> THAT’S THE BIG STORY FROM
THE WHOLE START OF THIS , BRIAN.
I’M NOT SURE THAT ANYTHING WE’VE
DONE AND I LOOK FORWARD TO YEARS
FROM NOW, WHEN ALL OF THE
EMOTION IS STRIPPED AWAY AND
WE COULD ACTUALLY LOOK AT ALL OF
THE  VIROLOGY AND ALL OF THE
EPIDEMIOLOGY AND THE DATA.
I’M NOT SURE THERE’S GOING TO BE
ANYTHING THAT WE DID AT ALL,
SHUTTING DOWN SCHOOLS, SENDING
PEOPLE HOME, REQUIRING MASKS,
ALL OF IT.
I THINK IT WAS MOSTLY COSMETIC
THEATRE, BRIAN.
I THINK THE DATA IS GOING TO
REFLECT THAT THE VIRUS WAS GOING
TOUGHIER PEOPLE FELT LIKE THEY
NEEDED TO DO SOMETHING EVEN
THOUGH MOST OF THE THINGS THAT
WE DID HAD ALMOST ZERO IMPACT,
AND SOME OF THE THINGS, I MEAN
LOOK AT SCHOOLS.
THE DATA ON SCHOOLS WHEN KIDS GO
BACK-TO-SCHOOL SHOWS THERE
AREN’T THESE SUPER SPREADER
EVENTS WHEN KIDS GO
BACK-TO-SCHOOL.
THE DATA IS CLEAR THAT’S WHY
MANY EUROPEAN COUNTRIES DON’T
REQUIRE KIDS TO WEAR MASKS BY
THE WAY, BECAUSE THEY ALSO DON’T
WORK, BUT I LOOK FORWARD, I
THINK WE’RE GOING TO SEE , I
REALLY DO, 30 YEARS FROM NOW
PEOPLE WILL LOOK BACK AND SAY
THIS WAS THE VIETNAM WAR ON
STEROIDS IN THIS COUNTRY.
BRIAN:  75% OF THE ELIGIBLE
VACCINATION POPULATION HAS
GOTTEN AT LEAST ONE SHOT, PLUS
THE NATURAL IMMUNITY, WE’RE
DOING A LOT BETTER THAN ANYONE
THINKS MEANWHILE WHAT’S CLICKING
IN OUTKICK?
>> WE’RE GETTING READY FOR OUR
BUS TOUR, BRIAN.
WE’LL BE IN NASHVILLE THIS
WEEKEND FOR GEORGIA
VANDERBILT AND THEN GOING DOWN
TO TUSCALOOSA AND THEN WE’LL BE
IN COLLEGE STATION, TEXAS FOR
ALABAMA/TEXAS A &M,
FANTASTIC CROWDS COMING OUT TO
SEE US LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING
PEOPLE THIS WEEKEND AND CAN’T
WAIT TO BE BACK ON THE ROAD AT
SOME OF THE BIG COLLEGE FOOTBALL
STADIUMS WHERE PEOPLE ARE GOING
OUT AND LIVING THEIR LIVES,
WITHOUT FEAR, AND IT’S GREAT TO
SEE PEOPLE BACK TO NORMAL.
BRIAN:  CLAY TRAVIS IS WORKING
SEVEN DAYS A WEEK FOR THE LAST
TWO YEARS YOU HAVE A LOT OF
VACATION DAYS BUILT UP WHEN YOU
GET TO YOUR 70S YOU CAN ACTUALLY